et le 7 8 sport comme tous les lundis
c'est avec Anthony Anthony bonsoir ce
soir
exactement bienvenue dans ce 7 8 sport
une édition spéciale consacrée au golf à
10 jours de l'Open de France je reçois
le directeur du Golf National Olivier
roche bonsoir à vous et vous êtes
accompagné d'Anne Lepage membre de la
direction des sports de la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
bonsoir évidemment comme d'habitude tous
les résultats du week-end en fin d'année
il y a quelque petites choses à dire
donc je le disais nous sommes à 10 jours
1 de l'Open de France Olivier Le Golf
National est dans les derniers réglages
le parcours est prêt parcours est prêt
il lui reste encore 5-6 jours
effectivement il est pratiquement
on dirait mature pour recevoir on a reçu
beaucoup trop de précipitations pour
avoir un parcours parfaitement comme on
voulait l'imaginer
un petit peu humide mais l'herbe est de
qualité vraiment d'une qualité il faut
dire que le week-end a été encore c'est
bien arrosé malheureusement sur sur le
golf national après il nous reste cinq
six jours mais on n'a jamais eu un
parcours aussi bien préparé donc on est
très très fiers on a encore beaucoup de
travail et c'est un peu comme tous les
grands événements jusqu'à la dernière
minute on prépare on prépare et là il
nous reste cinq jours donc on est bien
pour l'instant tout va bien on reviendra
un petit peu plus sur la préparation et
les coulisses puisqu'on a fait un on est
allé voir justement c'est coulisses il y
a quelques jours cet Open de France
c'est un Open qui se prépare sur 12 mois
c'est pas sur 5-6 mois depuis février on
y pense dès la fin de l'Open précédent
ben en fait si on parle oui en termes de
logistique on fait un débrief 5 6 jours
après l'Open de France pour bien
remettre en valeur tout ce qui s'est
bien passé tout ce qui s'est passé bien
passé et on repart dès l'année dès
septembre on reprend l'Open
effectivement donc pour nous ce qui est
très difficile au golf national c'est
d'avoir un open tous les ans peu de golf
ont un open aussi important ou une
manifestation sportive tous les ans
c'est récurrent et puis c'est
d'envergure international c'est
internationale et c'est vrai que quand
on doit se positionner pour faire des
travaux des aménagements en fait on a
très peu de temps parce que entre le
temps où on fait nos travaux la pousse
l'air enfin toutes ces toutes ces choses
c'est pas c'est pas aussi simple que ça
et pour donner l'impression que ça a
déjà existé d'une année sur l'autre il
faut vraiment bien anticiper mais mon
nom on a l'exercice on connaît bien vu
que ça fait 10 ans ou 15 ans d'affilée
que le pone est organisé à l'Open
d’offre au Golf National pardon
donc on est sur ce registre c'est pas
simple mais c'est l'exercice c'est
intéressant en terme de travaux il y a
aussi toute cette espace village que
vous aménagez toujours aux quelques
semaines auparavant qui est en pleine
finition si je crois alors là c'est pire
que finition mais si vous avez des
images on va voir que ça ressemble à on
y allait il y a quelques jours ça
ressemble pas forcément à ce qu'on
imagine à la fin donc là c'est c'est
comme comment dire des stands ou un
une manifestation
comme dire au salon de Versailles
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à la dernière minute
tant que c'est pas ouvert mais on peut
encore modifier les chose là on a sur un
registre où on a modifié l'emplacement
du village l'accueil du public donc on a
fait beaucoup de travaux cet hiver et on
va voir si ça si ça fonctionne bien
justement pour l'instant ça monte bien
mais on voit les images et c'est on est
très très content de ce qui s'est passé
on va voir si le public est au
rendez-vous pour le moment ce qu'on a
imaginé est à la hauteur de ce qu'on a
ce qu'on avait imaginé justement et
c'est très satisfaisant alors il n'y a
pas que l'aspect esthétique à Catherine
puisque ce parcours doit être d'une
qualité exceptionnelle vous le disiez
depuis 6 mois et il est la nouvelle arme
secrète du Golf National il s'appelle
Alejandro Reyes il est il arrive tout
droit d'Espagne il est le nouveau
responsable de l'entretien il façonne
les Green les fairway pour l'Open de
France mais aussi en vue de la Ryder Cup
allez rendre au Reyes grandit ton
Andalousie en Espagne juste à côté d'un
parcours de golf et son amour pour les
Green s'éveille très vite
les scènes que qui allégation quand
c'est
coupé pour le matin et ça a été
c'était bien
à la fin de ses études d'ingénieur
agronome en Espagne à les randrons se
spécialistes dans l'entretien des
parcours de golf en Grande-Bretagne il
aurait alors pu choisir la facilité en
s'occupant d'un grand stade de football
c'était mal connaître ce magicien du
gazon les terrains de défauts est-ce que
c'est les mains surfaces et c'est très
uniforme dans les terrains et c'est
toujours les mêmes c'est comme on dit
c'est
c'est loin
des
fairways ici on a tous les différents
surfaces et les rats les grilles les
départs les tabliers et les banques
avant de poser ses valises en France il
a déjà bichonné six parcours de golf de
l'autre côté des Pyrénées à peine 30 ans
il fait déjà partie des meilleurs et
tire cette excellence presque unique
dans son attention au gazon qu'il traite
comme ses propres enfants malades ne
serait rien sans son équipe d'entretien
ils sont près d'une vingtaine présent
toute l'année sur les 18 trous de
l'Albatros pour donner forme au parcours
le jour J en l'espace de 6 mois
l'intégration espagnole semble se faire
sans accroc il est formidable il est
très très compétent
extrêmement motivé
il est enthousiasmé voilà par le site
qui est vraiment fantastique et par
cette épreuve aussi et puis surtout pour
la préparation de la Cup 2000 2018
la rider Cup c'est aussi la mission
d'Alejandro Reyes chaque Open de France
permettra de préparer le parcours à
commencer par l'édition 2013 du 4 au 7
juillet prochain
Olivier avec Alejandro vous avez
dénicher une perle on a l'impression non
ouais c'était on va pas on va pas
refaire toute l'histoire mais on a fait
un recrutement international on a eu on
a rencontré des Néo-Zélandais des
Australiens des Espagnols on a fait
toutes les toutes les toutes les
nationalités on a reçu aussi pourquoi
international ce qu'on a pas en France
la pépite dont parle Anthony on a eu des
sens on a eu des candidatures françaises
alors après on va pas se prendre on va
pas se mettre sur un registre
international ce que je veux dire c'est
que on a peu de Français qui ont un
niveau et une connaissance
internationale c'est-à-dire une
connaissance à être aller travailler à
l'étranger pour connaître ce qui se
passe ailleurs qu'en France et il faut
avouer qu'en France notre qualité
première n'est pas forcément les langues
c'est pas forcément les langues donc
trouver un Français qui parle
parfaitement l'anglais vu que les
instances internationales sont quand
même anglaise et qui a cette
connaissance et avoir fait le choix
d'avoir vécu à l'étranger pour connaître
justement le les différents parcours
américains anglais ou français il y en
avait il y en a pas il y en a pas vu ou
ce qu'on a rencontré n'était peut-être
pas assez compétent par rapport au
sommité qu'on a reçu pour revenir sur
les entretiens très vite on a reçu
vraiment des des graines qui peuvent
internationaux dont celui de loclement
en Écosse qui peut-être un des meilleurs
greenpeople d'Europe qui voulaient venir
qui voulait venir au golfe national on a
reçu aussi comment dire le greenkeeper
actuellement du Bel fric à organiser
deux riders Cup donc on a vraiment reçu
des pointures on a fait le choix
d'Alexandro pour des raisons
assez simples d'une part quand on
déplace un greenpeople étranger il faut
prendre toute sa famille avec donc c'est
vrai que c'est un coup il faut être
clair et on a fait le choix surtout de
la jeunesse avec un espagnol qui qui
nous a démontré toute sa toute sa fougue
j'ai pas j'ai pas noté dans l'entretien
si il s'est exprimé en français ou pas
faut savoir qu'en septembre qu'on a fait
son premier entretien avec lui c'était
qu'en anglais vu qu'il avait des
diplômes américains qu'il avait réalisé
en anglais et deux mois après quand on a
fait le deuxième et quasiment entretien
dans l'entretien final pour le
recrutement il a fait qu'en français
c'est à dire qu'en deux mois et demi il
a appris le français suffisamment bien
pour prendre le risque de faire
l'entretien en français donc il nous a
demandé
et c'est assez incroyable d'avoir un
voilà ce que j'appelle un gamin vu que
il a presque génération d'écart avec moi
et une telle une telle envie une telle
connaissance une telle performance dans
son travail il a notamment quand même
été recruté par par Jack niglos qui est
donc il travaille pour travailler il a
travaillé d'ailleurs qu'avec lui c'est
une des plus belles signatures qu'on
puisse avoir sur son CV à 29 ans de
sortir Jack niclos design donc c'est
vrai que naturellement en plus ancien
golfeur professionnel qui a toujours de
ce sport il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'atouts
et donc on a pris le choix de prendre un
risque avec Alexandro pour finir sur le
recrutement il est plus facile de se
dire au bout de six mois on s'est trompé
sur un espagnol qui est célibataire qui
a 29 ans il peut rebondir faire venir
quelqu'un qui a 45 ou 50 ans
d'Écosse ou toute sa famille se déplace
et lui des routines moins ça va pas
c'est un risque qu'on voulait pas
prendre aujourd'hui on est très très
fier du travail qui fait et comme vous
l'avez vu sur les images je pense que le
parcours même si c'est toujours
difficile de comparer d'une année sur
l'autre le parcours est réellement
fantastique cette année pour des
registres peut-être que nous commun des
mortels on peut pas voir mais vraiment
en plus voilà il y a des subtilités
cette année le parcours depuis
qu'Alexandre est arrivé on tombe
l'intégralité des Green et des départs
avec la simplex c'est-à-dire une machine
où on est derrière à pied c'est les
machines qui sont les plus qualitatives
les plus performantes
et quand on revient à un côté très
artisanal on retrouve une qualité
exceptionnelle et je pense qu'en France
pas un golf à aujourd'hui et aussi pour
des problèmes de coups vu que ça prend
plus de temps pour préparer le parcours
qui à l’année coupe ses green ses
départs avec ces machines donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu une revue d'effectif
complet une réorganisation complète et
il a quelque chose que les autres n'ont
pas et c'est pour ça qu'on l'a embauché
pour revenir sur l'Open de France la
compétition à proprement parler et il y
a de plus en plus de joueurs de niveau
top niveau européen qui viennent
notamment cette année entre McDonald's
Jacquelin chez les Français et c'est
quoi cet attrait qu'est-ce qui fait cet
attrait du de l'Open de France c'est
parce qu'il y a la rider Cup derrière
ils se disent on va commencer déjà à
voir un peu ce que donne le parcours
en toute honnêteté je pense pas qu'un
joueur professionnel je ne le suis pas
mais je pense pas qu'un joueur
professionnel ce projet déjà à 5 ans
faut savoir que pour rentrer dans le
rider Cup c'est des points qu'on glane
uniquement l'année et demi avant le
tournoi donc peu de référence à la rider
même si forcément c'est bien de jouer
c'est bien de jouer le comment dire le
parcours de la Ryder à côté de ça il y a
un travail formidable qui est fait par
le promoteur donc effet Gaulle
production qui est une filiale de ASO et
de la fédération pour organiser l'Open
et on a une personne qui s'occupe à
l'année d'aller sur les tournois qui va
aux États-Unis qui fait qui fait de la
prospection ce qu'il faut savoir pour
faire venir les joueurs il faut les
rencontrer faut leur parler il faut leur
séduire et on est le seul pays en France
qui ne propose pas des pyrens monnaies
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne payent pas les
joueurs pour apparaître ainsi on leur
propose d'autres d'autres choses donc on
leur donne des facilités on s'occupe de
leur femme parce que c'est très
important à Paris mais on se refuse de
donner de l'argent c'est difficile dans
ce contexte
Tiger Woods par exemple alors Tiger
Woods c'est pas difficile on connaît le
contrat c'est un contrat de 3 millions 3
millions de dollars pour qu'ils viennent
par an et c'est un contrat minimum sur
trois ans il y a des petits à côté donc
vous savez que ça va coûter 10 millions
de dollars pour faire venir
de sport mais je pense que enfin il y a
comment dire il y a plein de meeting si
on prend un parallèle avec l'athlétisme
Usain Bolt se déplace pas si il est pas
il est pas payé pour se déplacer donc il
faut accepter le jeu et je pense que le
sport de haut niveau c'est une carrière
même si le golf est un petit peu plus
long en carrière le football c'est
pareil à 30-32 ans c'est fini donc ils
doivent gagner beaucoup d'argent au
début moi ça me choque pas donc pour
revenir à votre question les joueurs
viennent parce que le parcours est
extraordinaire il l'a toujours été et ça
c'est c'est j'irai bêtement c'est la
grâce de l'architecte qui a fait un
parcours que tout le monde apprécie et
c'est comme ça on peut pas revenir
dessus maintenant il est très très bien
entretenu et ce travail fait avec cette
c'est Bruno rebeu donc l'ancien
directeur de l'ancien directeur de
Roland-Garros qui s'est reconverti dans
ce dans ce job
il passe son année entière à se déplacer
à rencontrer les joueurs et à leur
donner envie de venir et ça paye et
parmi ces top 20 européens vous avez un
favori peut-être non moi j'ai pas de
favoris parce que le golf nous a appris
à être humble a beaucoup d'humidité par
rapport
comme par rapport à ça maintenant il y a
des joueurs français qui sont en pleine
forme et Alexander Levy qui a fini 3e du
German open donc c'était pas plus tard
que dimanche et il y a un coût de la
tête donc il aurait pu gagner Jacquelin
n'oublions pas qu'il est vraiment en
forme enfin voilà les joueurs français
sont très en forme et moi je suis
toujours très cocorico donc je resterai
très cocorico maintenant on a un
Américain exceptionnel qui vient qui
vient cette année
ce serait fabuleux qui se retrouve dans
les dernières parties parce que il a
joué les championnats du monde en 94 il
était avec Tiger Woods en amateur quand
il a quand ils ont gagné les ces fameux
championnats du monde ce serait génial
que ce buzz qu'on essaye de monter avec
ces joueurs américains parce que quand
on a la quand on parle de Planet golf il
y a indéniablement l'équipe européenne
et aussi l'équipe américaine donc s'il y
en arrivait à avoir quelques américains
qui viennent en plus sans les payer ce
serait vraiment génial pour toi qui
viennent pour la Ryder Cup et il
viendront forcément là pour le coup pour
la